I was working with the John Barry 7
which was a group and we did the music
film music for the film beat girl which
you wish you so charmingly mentioned and
also some other little bits and pieces
and Peter Honda's you see is the editor
on on those Bond films he'd heard it and
when he actually saw and heard Monte
Norman's idea of what the main title
should be he felt that it needed the
beat girl treatment when Peter hunt gave
John Barry this piece of manuscript
would sounded nothing actually really
interpreting wise like the James Bond
theme that we know and come to love over
the years we worked on it and played it
and sped it up a little bit and put a
little bit of aggression into it and we
finished up with the James Bond theme
which now has lasted for 50 years it's
amazing I'm so pleased to have been part
of it John and I'm sure that Don's the
same that's what we've been associated
with is is amazing that it's gone down
through the years
tell me Vic what did you get paid for
that job just checking my tax man's in
the room a $15.00 and and you've spent
that now I've just spent it yes I bought
a new pair of shoes for the gig yes yeah
from the thrift shop now good you know
it's interesting that actually that
classic guitar that you were playing and
most people think that that's an
electric guitar it's not it's an
acoustic it no it's a it's a an english
clifford essex paragon deluxe which was
made in london in 1939 and I bought it
from another fellow guitar player I was
actually having a hard time and we
exchanged cash for that guitar and I've
had that guitar ever since
yeah and it's it's a what they call an F
hole acoustic cello body with a dearmond
pickup on it which I think gave it I
don't know what do you think from
hearing it here
not exactly the same acoustics but I
think it gave the tune an added impact
and that its sound which is again
carried it down through the years you
know you played on the gold finger score
yeah on the recording of the song and
and in the score so you were you were
there when Shirley Bassey actually sang
Goldfinger in the studio well I what
happened because we got into the studio
and Shirley Bassey can be a little
temperamental it is she's a wonderful
artist wonderful singer and I admire her
immensely but on this particular time
she was a stressed or John Berry was
digging at her or whatever they get this
song correct and we went through it
about three four five times rehearsals
now we took it about two or three times
and I think I forget who was in the box
may might have been Norman Newell or
John Burgess it was the producer and
they said we need one more because the
last note is not right
so John Berry said she said now come on
come on Shirley you've got you've got to
really try and get this last note so
anyway there was silence because he was
in one of these acoustic booths that you
couldn't really see her but you could
hear her okay and she said alright
what's heard well she won't speak like
that see one more time and that's it see
so anyway there was a a scuffling going
on just like Tom Jones and her other
both are saying and suddenly she said
this is it here we go and over the top
of this booth came her bra see
so she'd obviously taken the little bit
of tension out of her body and she she
she got that last note at you here on
the screen